[Music]
ah spaghetti wait something's not right
reverse reverse a little bit more okay
whipped cream a bit weird to have that
with spaghetti but let's go with it
what ice cream
ah it's ice cream everybody strawberry
sauce white chocolate oh yes spaghetti
ice cream thank you to whoever came up
with that ich bin dalio fontanella
offender from spaghetti ice wow
okay let me get this straight pasta and
gelato two iconic italian foods that
have beautifully collided in
germany oh
right but before all our italian viewers
get angry at us we should explain that
it was dario's italian grandfather who
started the family's ice cream obsession
but it was dario whose invention changed
the world
i know this is
[Music]
the family began selling the new
invention from their ice cream parlor
kinder van
trainer
so apart from making children cry the
dish proved popular actually popular
might be an understatement
spaghetti
medium
[Music]
his invention has catapulted him to ice
cream fame
[Music]
but the most important thing isn't ice
cream fame the important thing is the
fun of it all
eyes in front of spaghetti become this
is naturally in the total you're telling
me it freaked me out a little bit at the
beginning of this video
but i sort of want it now
you